We Begin tonight with a special look at
the UPenn Biden Center for diplomacy and
engagement made possible it appears by
the Communist Party of China now in 2014
shortly after establishing the academic
center all in Biden's name and appoint
appointing the former vice president to
lead the new Department
54 million dollars in an anonymous
donations from China magically just
poured right into the coffers now last
year a government Watchdog demanded that
these sketchy donations be investigated
out of National Security concerns and
now lo and behold breaking this week a
trove of top secret classified documents
including sensitive compartmented
information from the Obama
Administration they were uncovered in a
private unsecured office at the Biden
Center for diplomacy and engagement in a
folder that was marked VP personal now
this reportedly includes secret material
real surrounding the UK Iran Ukraine now
to put it simply thanks to Joe Biden
America's most sensitive secrets were
floating around in an unsecured office
that was bought and paid for by the CCP
now perhaps something nefarious is a
play or maybe it's Joe Biden he's just
like Sandy Berger he's sloppy just being
sloppy remember Sandy Berger he took
documents he shoved them down his pants
his backside and his socks and everyone
said on the Democratic side he's just
sloppy he didn't do it on purpose it
accidentally fell into his pants now
either way according to the media mob
and the Democratic party this is a
serious offense let's go back and listen
to what Biden said only four short
months ago when he was on 60 Minutes one
of those rare interviews he gives take a
look
when you saw the photograph of the top
secret documents laid out on the floor
at Mar-A-Lago what did you think to
yourself
looking at that image
how that could possibly happen how one
anyone could be that irresponsible
and I thought what data was in there
that may compromise sources and methods
by that I mean names of people who
helped or et cetera and it just uh
totally irresponsible
how could anyone be that irresponsible
all right tonight maybe Biden should be
asking himself that question now of
course Joe Biden he doesn't need to
defend himself why should he he's got
Don Lemon he's got liberal Morning Joe
he's got the ladies of the view he's got
two fake news networks msdnc fake news
CNN he's got the Washington Post the New
York Times three networks ABC CBS NBC
and dozens of other outlets that are
more than happy to defend the president
Against All Odds take a look
the Department of Justice is reviewing
classified documents found in a personal
office for President Joe Biden this
discovery appears to be very different
from what happened at Mar-A-Lago we'll
explain this is going to be politicized
I imagine it is already been politicized
by those on the right and the former
president well we all know that Trump is
a liar and a thief
so it's not that big a jump to say that
he obstructed and he lied we don't think
that Biden is a liar and a thief so we
give him the benefit of the doubts but
there's no comparison here okay all
right so this is what the kids would
call false equivalency or what Aristotle
in any of his writings would call uh
Malarkey and I agree
all right for two long years there was
no oversight at all of the Biden
Administration not from the Democratic
House and Senate not from the
politicized doj certainly not from the
media mob but that is all about to
change and by the way not a moment too
soon under Biden the IRS has been
targeting get this they've been
targeting not the riches they always
claim but working and middle class
Americans at a far greater rate than
wealthy Americans and make no mistake
this will get even worse if Biden gets
his way and more than doubles the size
of the IRS with 87
000 new agents more than double now of
course the IRS will of course need all
the help it can get to squeeze Americans
to pay for Biden's out of control
spending but now not only is Biden
coming for your paycheck but he's also
coming for your stove you heard me right
that's right the White House is now
attempting to ban all gas ovens and
burners that's like half the country
we'll have to maybe we'll get Joe Biden
stoves delivered to our house for free
any anyways predicated by the green New
Deal these radical extremists in the
Democratic party they of course they
want to control the way what you now
cook I thought Michael Bloomberg was bad
when he took away my big gulp but they
want to control the way you eat the way
you travel the way you power your home
the way you power your car what about
your chainsaw your lawnmower and God
forbid if you ever used a leaf blower
they want to control every aspect of
your life from Cradle to grave womb to
the tomb now seemingly the only thing
they don't want to control is our
Southern border now Biden is even taking
down barriers in Arizona all while
building his own wall around his Beach
House apparently thinks walls work in
Delaware now the president must be held
accountable and tonight there's really
one group of people that allow now ready
to put in checks and balances to his
power and they are sitting in this room
tonight hey Sean Hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to Fox News YouTube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it anywhere else